Okay. Did you find anything interesting? There are
a couple of possible things that I've noticed. The
first is that not all codons have an amino
acid. You'll notice over here, UAA, UAG, and UGA
all code for something called a stop codon.
They don't even have an amino acid associated with
them. You might also have noticed redundancy. Leucine is
coded by C U U, C U C, C
U A and C U G. All four of those code for leucine. this is
considered redundancy. And then we look up here: U U A, U U G. That also codes
for leucine. But not every amino acid has
that redundancy. For example, only one codon codes
for tryptophan symbolized by Trp and W here.
A third possible thing I noticed was that,
it seems when there is redundancy, and you
get several condons for one amino acid, it's
always the third position that seems to be
unimportant. GU anything will give me Valine. GC anything
will give me Alanine. AC anything will give
me Threanine. CC anything will give me Proline.
So it seems as if, biologically speaking, this
third position may not be so important in distinguishing
different amino acids the same way that the first
or the second letter in the codon would be.